PROFESSOR: OK.
So time to complicate
the model a little bit
to get more interesting
physics from it.
So what am I going to do?
I'm going to add an extra term.
So the system goes
now to an H of t
that is going to have
the alpha t over 2.
And now it's gonna have a
little term of diagonal.
So there's several ways
of thinking about this.
H12 is going to be
constant in time.
So it's a number.
H12 star is it's
complex conjugate.
If you're looking at t equals
0, H becomes just H12, H12 star.
And the energy eigenstate
or the energy eigenvalues
of this matrix are plus
or minus the norm of H12,
the absolute value of H12.
Just put a couple of lambdas,
calculate the eigenvalues.
It involves H12 times
H12 star, which is
the square of the norm of H12.
And the energies are those.
So look at what's happening
in your energy diagram
as a function of t.
At t equals 0, there are two
energies, H12 and minus H12.
Those are the energies
at time equals 0.
We're trying to get the analog
of what was going on there.
And now you could
say, OK, at time
equals 0, that's what I get.
What do I get at large times?
Well, at large times,
these are dominant.
And these are very small.
So you must get something
similar to these arrows here.
So what I'll draw
here is this and this.
And I cannot trust this
here for small time.
But presumably, this is about
right here and about right here
and about right here
and about right here.
And the states must be
the same one, 0, 1 here;
0, 1; 1, 0; 1, 0.
So that's what you know just
without doing any calculation.
That's what your system does.
And now, a
Hamiltonian in general
doesn't get levels crossing.
That requires a coincidence like
having no off-diagonal element.
So actually, what this
will give you is this.
So that's how the system will
look as a function of time.
Those are the energy
levels as a function
of time, the instantaneous
energy levels.
At every instant of time,
you now have the energies.
These are the energies
of this matrix,
the energies, the eigenvalues.
One line computation, our E
plus minus equal plus or minus
square root of H12
squared plus alpha
squared t squared over
4, so plus or minus.
So this is E plus
and E minus of t.
All right.
So here we go.
We have a real system.
And we have something
quite interesting actually.
When you let H12 go to 0,
you're back to that place.
And you just zoom through
like here you did.
You just go through
and go through.
So when the levels
do that, you just
continue through any
particular state you were in.
You don't start here
and then go here.
You just go through.
That's what you prove here.
And therefore, when you take
the limit of H12 going to 0,
if H12 goes to 0,
these things collapse.
And you're back there.
And you zoom by through.
So when H12 will be
very, very small,
you will be likely,
in fact, more likely
to make the transition
than not to make it.
So if you have a system for--
this is just a micron separated
here, a milli-electron volt--
let's be more precise here--
you're more likely to
zoom through and make
the nonadiabatic transition
because this will not
be an adiabatic process.
They're getting to
close to each other.
On the other hand,
if you are far away,
you're going to be
very unlikely to make
the nonadiabatic transition
because you are very separated.
The nice thing
about this problem
is that it can be
solved analytically.
Not terribly easy.
It involves a little bit
of hypergeometric functions
and some differential equations.
But it can be solved.
You will solve it
numerically in the homework.
I will say a few words about it.
And we'll discuss the
transition in this case.
And the answer is
known analytically.
It's a very famous result.
In fact, many people
have written papers trying
to give simple derivations
of this answer.
So in order to just
write the answer
and to see how it looks--
so this is the answer
for a transition--
we try to discuss the notion
of adiabatic process here.
When is this
transition adiabatic?
And what we do is this.
You can imagine taking a tangent
here and another tangent here.
And when it hits the lines,
the linear lines that we
plotted here, bring them down.
So you get a rectangle here.
So you hit the
alpha t over 2 line.
And you call this 2 tau
d or 2 tau, no, tau d.
OK.
So let's figure out
what that is because I
say that this time is
the time that going up
on the line, alpha t over
2, this time 2 tau d,
you get the height, H12.
That means that H12 is alpha
times 2 tau d divided by 2.
So tau d is H12 over alpha.
So tau d is usually thought
as the timescale associated
to the change in
the Hamiltonian.
That is you have an
original Hamiltonian, that's
where this linear [INAUDIBLE].
And over a time 2d,
the shape is changed
into the final Hamiltonian.
This is the process in
which the original system
is changed into the new
system within this timescale.
The timescale tau d.
But we have another time
that is interesting here.
You see, while this
change is happening,
the separation of the energy
levels is by this distance H12.
So the Hamiltonian
at t equals 0,
the Hamiltonian looks
like 0, H12, H12, here.
And if you have two states
governed by such Hamiltonian
that is valid near
time equals 0,
there's going to be oscillations
between states here.
You can go from the first
state to the second state
with some frequency
governed by this number.
That is called the Rabi
frequency, Rabi oscillation.
It's something
you've done in 805.
In two-state systems,
you oscillate.
And the frequency of oscillation
between the states 1 and 2
is H12 divided by h bar or 2
pi divided by the period T12.
That's the definition
of the frequency.
So what do we have here?
The process is
adiabatic if the time
tau d for the change to happen
is much larger than the period
capital T12 of the oscillation.
So you can think of this
system during the time
it spends in this box like
a two-level system separated
by H12 that oscillates
between the two states.
And in that time, 2 tau d,
all the change is happening.
So you should have that
tau d is much bigger
than the period of oscillation.
And this corresponds
too because T12
is the inverse of
omega 12 to omega 12
tau d much greater
than 1, so either one.
And that would be
adiabatic condition.
Let's put the numbers here.
Omega 12 is H12 norm over h bar.
And tau d-- we often
found it there--
is H12 over alpha.
So over alpha.
So this is much greater than 1.
I don't know.
This 2 here has nothing
to do with that formula.
So this is the
adiabatic condition.
And this is reasonable.
You see, what is going
to make it adiabatic?
The more these branches are
separated, the more difficult
the transition, the better
the adiabatic approximation.
And it's this thing here.
The bigger this number,
the better you are.
The slower alpha is,
the lower the slope
is, the more time
it's going to take,
the better the
adiabatic approximation.
So this is really the thing.
And the final formula
that I will write here
is the probability for a
nonadiabatic transition
is exponential of minus
2 pi omega 12 tau d.
So the probability that you
cross the thing and jump
from this down to here is this.
It's suppressed by
the adiabatic factor.
And that's what you will
check in the homework.